une année sociale base indique de la
rédac oui je suis l'indiquent je sais
tout je vois tout et ce soir je dénonce
tout comme chaque semaine et je vais
commencer par ce qui s'est passé jeudi
dernier sur votre plateau cyril oui il
ya eu un des plus grands fous rires de
l'histoire acer de touche pas on parle
avec run & bike gros d'un instant aussi
vous souvenez alors quoi bien sûr il le
faut professeur à la ccao recevez le
professeur out enfin presque
et du coup bah c'était le plus beau jour
de la vie de rené c'était son jour de
gloire
enfin presque jusqu'à ce que tout
s'effondre regardez le pauvre nez on
n'aurait pas aimé être à sa place ce
jour là on ira mieux moi je suis pour
eux
voilà aujourd'hui c'est pas aujourd'hui
elle sait qu'elle me casser les couilles
en démarchant les chevilles ce soir
c'est un grand événement dans tp est
parce que nous recevons la personnalité
de l'année le professeur didier raoult
l'avenir en plateau dans quelques
instants
moi j'ai jamais caché que voilà je
comprenais jamais cet engouement auprès
du premier but ils ont dit ils arrivent
ils à lasser ceux qu'auchan en mode et a
dit je vais te le faire une bien pu dire
je vais le faire un nouvel quand même
mon bonnet maire de rodez faites vos
trucs et il va rentrer après il sera là
non non non je ne fais pas tu me le
faire
[Rires]
pas une ligne et qui nous emmerde
au futur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu dis est ce que voulait la surprise du
professeur a fait défaut n'est pas légal
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous avez aimé qu'elle était même mon
père m'a dit j'ai pleuré de rire dit
devant la prochaine fois tu as matelots
oui c'est sûr alors rené kamm toi
puisque j'ai un dossier qui risque de
compromettre sa carrière télévisuelle
voilà je ne diffuserait dans un instant
est-ce que d'abord priorité au retour
priorité aux comebacks c'était cette
semaine un retour exceptionnel celui de
l'animal
l'animal l'ambiance sur clash
recommandiez à hollywood
cyril hanouna qui est à ma droite était
très en forme cette semaine c'est un
amour de patron très spécial cette
semaine regardez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais allez vous faire saliver
comment votre curiosité pas déboussolés
je trouve que je fais énormément de
gétigné si j'arrive à gommer tous mes
gestes superflus je prends tu est un
super manceau
[Musique]
lisa je voulais finir ensemble
je sais ça va aller 2 je sais que vous
avez kane et ça me ferait plaisir si
vous faites un enfant et bad net il va
avoir 60 8 en retour ouais je bouffais
lok sabha bernard tu as fait une très
bonne émission y'a tu étais là
[Musique]
ça change et ça fait six mois que j'ai
pas joué je sais que je peux pas c'est
parce que tu as des grosses c'est pas
parce que je vais regarder tes vieilles
cependant que tu veux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous
là la voix est ce que vous pensez à
nathalie tu me connais pas nathalie très
merci nathalie mais sans ça je ne sont
pas vraiment alors et vous aviez
vraiment mal et je passe à germer
maintenant c'est bon jean michel est ce
que vous savez vous avez un vrai
problème jean michel un joli paquin ont
malheureusement jean michel vous répéter
toutes vos phrases avec deux fois trois
fois
parfois même plus on dire isabelle joly
jean michel se fait de plus en plus
vieux alors c'est bien beau de se faire
greffer des cheveux mais faut que le
cerveau suez veulent qu'on attaque une
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
cg remis deux fois regardez c'est
magnifique c'est la vache folle ces box
et la vache folle
après vérification de faire céder
[Musique]
mais kaka
[Applaudissements]
qui ces dernières années passionne le
plus grand fonds c'est à la ferme de
ligonnès ce père de famille catholique
rouge et de ses quatre enfants
c'est pas gagné c'est mignon mais
connaît un changement qui va finir pas
là
[Applaudissements]
pour une tagline barils il repart à la
nage par la nage
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vais y en a pas une dedans et ça me
donne c'est un fois un homme incroyable
on suivra les records si la semaine
prochaine même si un petit cochon de
lait est comme ça que vous avez déjà pas
du tout vous endurez pas du tout ça vous
êtes sur cette magnifique
attendez avant que je parte vous allez
voir on va faire redescendre ça parce
que vous me charrier bien enfin du tout
je voudrais bien charrier et j'ai une
revanche à prendre
il est d'abord revenons à rené à
l'hormone et je vous ai dit que j'avais
un dossier qui pouvait compromettre sa
carrière télévisuelle et bien rené vous
avez dit quelque chose tout à l'heure à
l'antenne quand on parlait de michel
cymes et vous nous l'aviez dit également
au début de la saison alors ce que je
propose aux téléspectateurs c'est qu'on
regarde ce qu'il a dit et puis on en
parle juste après sachez que l'indiquent
garde tout en mémoire
là il est fort à l'est indiquent à la
thématique et 1000 euros à celui qui
veut prendre une photo un jour avec un
pastis d'un mba j'ai parié 1000 euros et
ça fait des années pour moi j'ai jamais
déboursé 20 je ne vois jamais de papier
tu vois
[Rires]
alors alors alors vous l'avez répéter
tout à l'heure est ce que pouvait dire
comme ça devant la france entière
je ne mourra jamais nos pastis j'ai dit
je pari celui qui veut prendre un bain
passer d'un mba très bien mille euros
que bien très bien dans le bas
temps
voilà s'il vous plaît prenez l'affairé
de viol à vous et hilarant que j'ai dix
mille rossi qui veut pas même patrie je
suis indique 1000 euros et bien sortir
la carte bleue un espèce comme vous et
j'ai une image à tous ceux qui cherchent
pas seulement une légende c'est une
légende vivante
[Applaudissements]
ici le temps d'écouter ce que et schalk
ans a misé mais les vidéos que regarder
les vidéos que je fais regarder tout ça
et vous serez vraiment quoi de 10000
euros la journée toujours dit celle ci
j'ai mon ami ait jamais rentrer tout le
monde je ne vais pas m'en le débat riche
et va demander à montiel il va rue
marbeuf normalement la chronique se
terminer sur ça je pense que c'est bien
oui mais end se terminera pas sur ce à
quoi les quelque chose qui est pas passé
hier cyril c'est quoi vous étiez en
émission il ya 100 kg bilou et v dany
brillant qui était à côté très simple
puis pendant la chronique de luigi louis
duc c'est celui qui fait on va voir ce
qu'elles étaient tous les deux là vous
allez voir parce que hier vous avez dit
que je ressemblais à ça on peut voir la
photo s'il est d'accord
non mais non mais non parce qu'il dit
bien rasé lui et non et non j'ai pas dit
ça j'ai dit un peu con à manger dit vous
avez d'un très beau regard comme vous
oui et donc cherished une route
c'est une calomnie je n'ai pas accepté
alors luigi j'aime m'occuper de lui dans
un instant et vous serrez pas me gêner
tout le monde vous avez toujours été bon
comme ça non vous croyez vous êtes
toujours été aussi reluisant non non non
parce que vous savez que l'indiquaient
des archives par seconde en tapant alors
là donc je vais laisser passer ça c'est
la faute aux actes et lunettes ah c'est
pas une photo c'est encore pire que ça
non c'est une vidéo non série massa je
pense qu'à un moment vous avez abusé
quand celle que ce prix là ça fait dix
ans ça fait dix ans que travailler
ensemble c'est quand même temps
cinquantaine c'est un exploit a terminé
aujourd'hui
c'est légal est de retour à pau avec
cyril hanouna
à très bientôt à bientôt voilà nous
sommes de retour à pau alors là nous
sommes sur le boulevard des pyrénées non
loin du château henri iv et je suis dans
une formule 3 rebonds bois hier dans une
formule 3 donc je vais essayer de
m'extraire de cette voiture à mon avis
vous en avez pour 1h30 2h
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]